Forrest Johnson on the red-eye hauled
back from New York to face MPs wrong
side of the road wrong side of the law
his suspension of Parliament overturned
in court it's all a bit of a mess mr.
Johnson back into the bunker everyone's
come back the protestors and MPs to the
speaker on the March the Commons back in
business
welcome back to our place of work
[Music]
most people don't cheer being back in
the day job after time off but this lot
looking forward to getting stuck into
the p.m. fast the warm-up act the
Attorney General eating a thin slice of
humble pie except we lost we got it
wrong on the judgment of the Supreme
Court the government will abide by its
ruling straight back on the attack
disgrace furious with MPs for denying
the p.m. an election
[Applause]
the time is coming mr. speaker when even
these turkeys won't be able to prevent
Christmas
the chamber erupted in labor outraged
[Music]
[Applause]
then to the man himself the Prime
Minister utterly unrepentant blame in
Parliament for telling tales deciding
absolutely no disrespect to the
judiciary to say I think the court was
wrong the court was wrong to pronounce
on what is essentially a political
question at a time of great national
controversy and attacking opponents for
refusing to grant him an election out of
sheer selfishness and political
cowardice
[Applause]
unwilling to move aside and give the
people a say we will not betray the
people who sent us here
that's what they want to do trying to
goad his rivals to take this fight to
the ballot box they have until the house
rises today to table a motion of no
confidence in the government
and we can have that vote tomorrow but
Jeremy Corbyn not taking the bait Prime
Minister should have done the honorable
thing and resigned not alone in thinking
that
[Applause]
for the god of this country he should go
mr. Johnson can have his wish but with
one clear condition he says he wants a
general election
I want a general election
get an extension and let's have fun
Electra
grexit has been a pressure cooker for
our government for our Parliament for
our political parties for all of us and
tonight those tensions really erupted
everyone here is furious the Prime
Minister telling his opponents they must
give him an election his opponents
insisting that they won't do that until
he goes to Brussels and asked for a
brexit extension more anger more rancor
but all of these sides refusing to budge
this is parliamentary trench warfare out
here to both sides dug in
but brexit day is fast approaching
between then and now something we'll
have to give